and action reject Nation
assemble that was basically the same but
yeah absolutely yeah I tried doing it
earlier guys reject nation very good
must assemble Terror every morning were
we watching today Tara Transformers rise
of the beasts so Tara is uh my friend
who did not catch this in the theaters
and I said good because the day that I
had a screening to go watch this I had
to stay behind and handle a bunch of
editing while Coy and John went to go
watch it let's see so busy oh my God I'm
so busy friends got to see it and you
got left in the duck feel bad for me and
admire my dedication to his career and
so I was like all right I guess I'm
reacting to this movie now so I'm glad
you could be here with me today so you
know what to do ladies and gentlemen
leave a like on this video also
subscribe click the notification Bell I
don't know if our next reaction is up
here on this channel follow Tara
Erickson on her YouTube oh yeah
I'll ring the bell and subscribe follow
her please I'm so sorry Tara it's been a
very long day we were shooting this on
the Tuesday we're a billion trailers
have come out and I got a midnight shoot
ahead of me feel sorry for me and admire
my dedication to my crafts reaction not
so long or he's sticking with your own
copy of Transformers rise of the Beast
of course available for a super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page we
cover so many exclusive things over
there with reactional Heights and watch
songs included this intro is done it's
done let's watch this movie
[Music]
oh
I've always loved the sound design
Hasbro oh they make toys yes yes
welcome to my brain I made that they
make GI Joe oh yeah yeah there's a
legend that precedes the dawn of our
civilization so powerful that it
consumed entire planets as fuel ah if
you believe such a thing could be true
until the day we saw Unicron with our
own eyes
that voiceover is so freaking great
Unicron he wanted our greatest
technology the transwarf key and he sent
his most powerful henchman Scourge
Scourge you son of a
oh
awesome okay I'm excited oh my God this
is great it's like a king kong
Transformer
Primo whoa
air razor get us down now your time to
leave
them a primal
it's that Terror and I greet each other
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh he's gonna all right buddy damn this
is gonna be a fight you won't forget
taking this
savory
damn
[Music]
oh oh no the whoa that quick
whoa whoa benefits
Mighty Unicron
oh my
sacrifice will be our oath to preserve
the key no matter the cost
that's a cool shot
I alone Will Rain Supreme wow
[Music]
wow
holy
junk this is real pretty and mesmerizing
damn that's cool okay rise of the beasts
I'm into it
[Music]
government agencies worried about us
Tails us Sonic and Tails are there
nicknames
Power Rangers Hasbro yeah
no it's nothing it's fun Sickle cells
must be blocking the blood flow again
he's smart and capable you find this
alone we find it together together
one team on team word home team in it I
am now endeared to him
me too put your skills to work and get
you some real money yes I'm a dude can't
even afford cable it's my own foreign
nature of modern day capitalism
that's great
it's cool that they put the Twin Towers
back there oh yeah as a dirty reminder
awesome age of Extinction oh man you
guys know how I love my Dinosaurs the
police are here they busted an art
auction but they want a second opinion
would they trust an intern's opinion
looks like air razor
really and he has a there's like a thing
on his chest ah
cool
cool I'm gonna get a feature in Minerva
Julia
[Music]
I mean why is she not allowed in there
when she clearly knows way more than
everybody else she's an intern interns
should be allowed to do stuff I know
we're a little behind on the bill three
months behind and until your account is
current you can't bring your brother
here I've told you that he's 11 years
old yeah but money's money yeah man I'm
here for an interview with the head of
security Mr Bishop it's been canceled oh
that's too bad your own commanding
officer called me back said you were
brave but unreliable your head was
always somewhere else God we need that
character Arc by the end of this movie I
I the breakers and I can't have someone
like you mess up what I built uh what
yeah excuse you sir rude and you don't
know anything about me I know you don't
know how to be part of a team I think by
the end of this movie
you will learn how to be a part of a
team he won't be so independent they
give a ton of paper to Charities every
year to make themselves feel better
stop and it's about to be easy as hell
so why'd you wait the one going in there
doing it
um
I don't think that the statuette is
Horus the boys dated it around 5000 BC
right the Nubians they never even had
contact with the Egyptians until 600
years after that oh interesting it's not
some Egyptian god it's something else
yeah
so I guess when the primals came here
they came here like thousands of years
ago I think so and she said Inca and uh
what's the other one Jesus
[Music]
great excuse me yes oh oh cool that was
great if that impresses you wait till
the rest of the movie
oh is this gonna be a meat cute I hope
so he runs into her she's smart he's
smart ooh
robots in Disguise cool
uh portion it feels very Michael Bay a
little wiggle
feel that snagging
nice
oh
I had a little anxiety there
is she oh
girl you're gonna have to find some
gorilla glue or you're gonna be fired
it's a beacon okay
oh it's our boy
[Music]
that's so cool this cannot be calling
all Autobots calling our Autobots
yes
oh hell yes
RC what am I looking at Away Home ah
I have Goosebumps this is an emergency
can you hear me Mirage
hey you gotta operate it now you better
okay skit skedaddle yeah of course I'm
trying the course
oh see ya
now let's talk to your manifestation
now yo Rick what do we do no I cannot
hear you right oh you dick
oh man
yeah you did
[Music]
[Laughter]
top tier manifestation to make the car
stop
[Applause]
[Music]
yep saw that coming oh no oh no
prime time that cop is dead that cop is
way dead or maybe just um differently
abled now
oh cool cool awesome
oh yeah
oh it's got nipple chills
hahaha
[Laughter]
The Mirage
haha wow this is really well
orchestrated
how do they do that that's cool
I haven't cooped up forever dude
I can tell you how
back up well that's with the aggression
well I thought after the car chase we
were boys we gonna hit me
tough guy I like that
I like it a lot
the name's Mirage
fist bump yeah give me a little give me
a little give me a kill tap
there you go now we're friends
word
yes you're so freaking cool
I already like this way more than the
Michael Bay once life so much more it's
awesome
yes
so we got here
[Music]
who are you human I'm nobody I ain't
even seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
private Noah Diaz U.S army multiple
commendations a wizard with electronics
I will deal with your mistake later
it was thought to be lost thousands of
years ago it was once used to open
space-time portals yes it was Sir John
Rich planets throughout the Universe yes
yes after seven long years stranded on
Earth we finally found a way home seven
long years
in the new Museum on Ellis Island
no we can't
we can't what we need is a quiet way in
they have just the guy
how about him he could do it what about
for cash
you help us get this key so we can get
off this rock then you get to save your
brother I let you sell me
Ferrari cool I like how Optimus in this
one is standoffish against humans
because it's before all the events of
those Michael Bay ones hers was supposed
to be a pit stop a place for us to
regroup and the war back home Prime
feels like it's his fault we've been
stranding here like he has to fix it all
on his own poor Prime has guilt man you
need to switch it up you need to turn
into a helicopter or a speedboat or
something I got something way better
than that
I like this Mirage character yeah he's
great at least Mirage is one of us we
should not be relying on a human there
my friends I know one was good to you
Bailee Steinfeld you care
I do not want you going to that drive-in
theater anymore
oh Optimus but it's such a joy this is
going to be the Journey of how Optimus
learn to trust humans ah yeah all thanks
to this one gent finally the hunt draws
to a close
full shot they must have been looking
for thousands of years oh
are you okay killer Noah it's not what
it looks like it's
oh my God
what's going on here don't move
oh no no I like how their solution was
just blast a big hole in there and then
go retrieve it yeah
they just looks
scene
oh sneaky little spiders guys we got
company
let's go
come on now
[Music]
the way they're shot so cool
[Applause]
cool
yeah yes
uh oh no when an inferior being meets a
higher power
oh
wow good timing there scourge
well this reminds me of Jurassic Park
but with Transformers
oh good shot oh whoa that's spooky
nice
go find your friends I don't think a
door is going to stop him oh it did oh
it is oh okay all right New York's
finest doors right here
ooh smart yeah yeah fire extinguisher
blind them thanks
spray it
[Music]
damn you guys are good survivors
oh
the key get it
God damn dang it
man
oh oh we got right under the armpit no
no I don't like it
uh this is how you can do Transformers
action and you call yourself a crime is
would be ashamed
premise good reference
oh my goodness this is like sad to watch
I do not like seeing them little things
getting in my way
me
oh no no no no no no no no I don't ah
that makes me sad what that can't be
right
oh
no
[Music]
no yes
yes
it's her statue it's your statue I love
how the Transformers are like actual
characters and you can because you could
tell what's going on in the actions
and you care yeah
my dark master oh scourge's soul is too
dark for
it's just too dark this is like what I
wanted the Transformers movies to always
be yeah so I'm like So Satisfied right
now the Galaxy will once again be yours
to Feast on my master I should have
known better than to rely on humans
goddamn it's not his fault Optimus
Because of You Unicron will now use the
key to consume every planet in the
universe he doesn't have the key amen at
least not all of it you gotta learn to
not keep blaming not all of it broke the
key into two pieces for safe keeping
then splintered and went into hiding
smart I am the last of all kind it's in
Peru how do you know that it's the
symbols on the stone because I'm the
smartest one in the museum
if you can track those symbols to Peru
soak in the tarragons we need to get
there before they do
the transform key is our only way home
if this dude gets a hold of that thing
this game over
devour Earth I'm going out of the
question no offense you're
my home to a guy who couldn't even
protect his
ouch that's a sick burn Elena will you
lead us to this Temple she has to stop
the end of the world actually you'll be
saving Two Worlds even like the human
characters
uh
we'll be back
oh
I was literally wondering like how does
is he able to control his weight
distribution on here trying to stop the
end of the world the world's ending no
you know I'm not gonna let that happen
that's why I have to leave I'll go get
my things oh I love how this is
adjusting so well it's Greatest
Adventure it's too dangerous Chris and I
need you to stay here and take care of
Mom oh he's got to be the man of the
house now watch out for my brother if he
gets hurt I'm coming after you don't
worry I got Noah's back okay on team
home team son
they like messing the out of those
shots like that's insane I'm like
seamless how do they do that the
Transformers even look real in the day
yeah
that's freaking cool
oh
[Music]
yeah I'm walking to Peru
Stratosphere in a previous Transformers
movie but I'm not sure I don't remember
him but I also don't remember what I had
for breakfast so we gotta destroy it
they can't unite the key without both
pieces
we gotta think about us no you gotta
learn to work on a team exactly
wheel Jack needs to fix that power
steering
I've always taken in a harmonious moment
between a Serene butterfly unruffled
caterpillar
so where'd you get that accent what
accent you know what I'm saying I'm just
I'm saying it's cool I want to assume
that you speak Spanish too a little
racist her menu
so he just has an accent I guess I
thought he was going to respond in
Spanish
it's a festival that shuts down the
whole city guess it's a night Mission
then we must retrieve the other half
time is of the essence me and Elena will
do it y'all never make it two blocks
there's human security all around the
church well hiding Plain Sight we'll
blend in with the parade that's racist
Noah
y'all know it think fast starters
oh
and if you need help just holler
he's like a piece of Mirage now that's
awesome the way they necessitate the
humans in this is well done and I like
Noah and Optimus being at odds and
haven't overcome that I'm In Color Me
impressed Tara Color Me impressed
ASA I'm blending in man
hablo espanol I'm not racist
Autobots must be using their new pets to
reach
the turkey's gotta be in here somewhere
man they did that so fast yeah
not lined up right oh it's like a video
game oh cool they got a Hasbro it
there's another one
levels I hate it's been way too much
time trying to figure it out
nowhere
oh
I feel like there'll be a lot of people
like who would have done that by
accident
this moves yeah who moved that other one
you dead yet wait did you just call me
Sonic I think that's a temple
you can call Mirage what's another Sonic
character you call them knuckles I think
we found what we came here for
oh are you even pushing me
is your penis this small
oh it's already gone
I found something you see any symbols
two of them
that actually got me
hang tight I'm on the way cool
[Music]
people in Peru are freaking out right
now
you're tearing up our Pebble streets man
wow
do something you want me to do
oh yeah use your yeah
oh that was easy you got a gun this
whole time he didn't know that
[Applause]
Ah that's so cool
what the hell are you doing I'm going to
take that key and then take off his head
nice all right Opti
oh wow
all right
[Music]
shot
the f word
[Music]
nice shot that's awesome yeah grass
coming out of his mouth
yeah
hold on no
foreign
[Music]
holy moly you're going to die on this
Speck of dust I can think of no better
place to bury you ah man Voice work is
so good
holy
oh she'd be raised in hell
uh
uh not this time
oh no no
no no no
this is tearing up my soul they do a
really good job at establishing a
scourge's real threat a real jerk I just
realized where the plot is going I don't
ruin it though don't ruin it
yes
yes stay away from my friends oh Mirage
you boys got this
stranger danger
over here kitty kitty
stand down
oh come on
this is so awesome oh my gosh just a
build up to them finally encountering
each other and our leader Optimus Prime
Optimus Prime that's like my name he has
half of the key we must find the second
piece before he does where is it now
come me
I can sense how Optimus will come around
to the humans Optimus must come around
to the humans because they're helping
you little bro's got this thing about
using real names over the airwaves so
he gave me this to keep tabs on you I'm
sure I'm keeping my promise uh great
the crown destroyed our world we took an
oath dedicated to the preservation of
life and Earth has been a safe Refuge
that's where Optimus is going to be like
really ha ha
oh interesting so they're like they hang
out with the Maximus
this is amaru family of the last
descendants of a tribe that has watched
over us for hundreds of years
really and together we protected its
people and
oh
I have Goosebumps the maximals have
already sacrificed one home to protect
the Universe I won't risk losing another
as a leader
I know you understand
Prime is going to learn from his future
self
man she's gonna die I don't know
this is raw Energon
I've be yeah
it would take a great power to ignite it
greater than anything we have here oh
they could find that power I see that
you were surprised we entrust the key to
them I've been amongst them a long time
now
there is more to them than Meats
I love it
play on Transformers meets the eyes come
on I get I was with you
fail at this
killing my family down
yeah just like him Optimus Optimus
stubborn you think he's some some
general barking orders but all I see is
a big brother trying to protect his
family humans are well done thank you
this is really great right I love how
they reflect each other that's so good
especially when you compare it
are you okay no she's not okay and I
don't like seeing it she's becoming
corrupted it's like a Venom
mine
no
eraser no miss me no Elena get out of
here
we have to destroy no no no no no no man
but if you destroy that key
our home will be lost forever don't
it got all worked up
oh gosh she's turned this just got
personal
[Music]
oh what a cool shot oh no
wouldn't I kill you already no that's a
different one oh I'm the maximal that's
going to rip out your spark we'll see
about that
kill them
no no you can't kill your family oh
oh he has to kill her
that's so sad
[Music]
oh
yeah
that's really sad
I actually teared up over a Transformer
I was alone I would have been scream
sobbing you just feel like the care and
love they actually have for each other
you know yeah they did a really great
job like I thought we were just making
fun of this movie the whole time
by myself just taking it more serious
oh
[Music]
looks like some Two Towers Lord of the
Rings right there man
oh we believe that the battle with
Darkness will continue till all or what
I lost sight of that yes when we should
have been fighting the darkness together
as a team now they're all going to be
part of the home team all right
everybody Squad up
oh my God he's leading the team the only
way to stop this process is an access
code installed long ago as a safeguard
code was split along with a key of
course it was the one hiding her half of
the key it had markings in it they must
complete the access code if you will
show us the way Primal the
awesome if Noah and Elena reach the
central antenna
they could use the code to shut it down
and close the portal before Unicron
enters our atmosphere
if we are to die then we will die
fighting all as one hell yeah
protect the key don't let them get to
the bridge
what okay it's all right they're small
look at this lineup
heck yeah
maximals Auto Parts
[Music]
maximize
whoa my nipples are so hard right now
wow
[Music]
yes
yes that was great
[Music]
oh that's an awesome Hammer nice
someone can be a real fight oh man okay
there's a fight you want you got one yes
oh oh take that man
hey baby
oh my God oh my God yeah miss me
holy they're gonna kill off Mirage
I've had to kill him off
[Music]
to die
no one will remember this pathetic
planet and no one will remember you
nice what are you doing keeping my
promise
oh my God what
home home team hold team
[Music]
oh
why so many they're all dying but I
think the power from the blast can
ignite the stuff that's in the earth in
the planet and revive them as well
articulated yeah you
mean this world
is already mine
person like little Pebbles like a little
Bish I'm not gonna win this one
oh Jesus
he'd be sick whenever I want to give up
yeah we're always there telling me
tell him no
no
you have to but you're distracted I know
Hey guys you're so cute
oh he's alive I'm gonna need you to take
the wheel
yes yes
exo suit
yes you can
all right now let's do this
no names over the Airways
forget that
[Music]
oh that made me tear up I love it so
much
remember me oh
that was cute
whoa yes damn it's like an anime it's
gonna be a learning progress you think
you can take me on alone
he's not alone he is not alone no he's
not
so Rousey
oh
yes
dang it no
no
[Music]
no no
wow
see the power ignites it like I was
saying
yes
nice yeah get every lemon tendon yeah
laughs
no
yeah
oh yes yes
that's awesome that's so awesome
be
knocked you out yay I have come here to
kick ass
you've got to be kidding me
[Applause]
holy crap yes holy crap teamwork make
the Dream Work
oh yeah let's end this once for all
right I got this
holy nice
yes I want one
yes he is one of them now
[Music]
are we going into a Warner
yeah we are wow
dope
you will never see unicorn take this
world
come on girl you got this
you did it broccoli baby
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
[Music]
oh my God
this belongs to a friend of mine
like it feels like real anatomy where
they're like tearing them apart you know
what I mean I will destroy the key
myself your sacrifice becomes our oath
but what it has to be another way I can
give you everything you want then die
take that Unicron
[Music]
foreign
oh
nicely done
unicorn
is he dead
traps but not dead
sequel we will destroy him once and for
all
I am Optimus Prime leader of the
Autobots good wrap around
I am Noah Diaz
I gotta help save the universe in order
to save the people I love well then
that's what I'm gonna do
he's still financially struggling though
or maybe not she's gonna get a job
of course they thought about that still
broke right resumes a little thin
I just recently had a job
working internationally
it was in South America it was really
just like work work work work that's a
shame because I heard the food is really
good in Peru oh yeah I was like why
does he seem evil
you have Terracon who are you like the
CIA or FBI or we are a secret government
organization we specialize in global
threats no and we'd love to have
you join the fight
you and your whole team the big guys
no idea what you're talking about are
they doing what I think they're doing I
want you to know
in lieu of the things of a Grateful
Nation we will be taking care of your
brother Chris's Health Care oh my god oh
I think they're building out a universe
are you serious save the world Ken it's
the least we can do
your brother's gonna be just fine
the card is gonna Chris was right by the
way
no names over the airwaves
this has to be what I think it is oh
[Music]
GI Joe
oh
whoa oh damn
they're gonna cross them over
oh my goodness
my nipple chills just got so hard right
now you can literally see them again
holy junk I was not I saw a mouth and
Joe to the camera because I was like
I think that's what they're doing
but I'm not 100 sure right now
oh
he's finally doing the mechanical issues
this is a complete waste of your skills
and my expertise I think it came out
pretty good
thank you
ah this car is special
oh it's a jigsaw puzzle made of garbage
The Joint don't even start yo Mirage
it's gonna show
[Music]
yeah paint job what is back this dude
said I wasn't even gonna start
hahaha
oh
damn what an exciting ass
that's an exciting ass ending right
there
dang that movie was good that movie was
so fun I got goosebumps like four times
I was I was like
enveloped in that event like it got to a
point where I'm like I my eyes are not
leaving the screen I'm So Into what's
happening right now ever I teared up
like three times I know like I was not
expecting that me neither I was like I
felt I just I was with it I felt it the
way they set all the characters up it
just throughout from the very beginning
you're just like man I really care and I
always complain about like if if there's
a cool movie that has cool stuff and
they don't make us care I ate that and
this movie did a beautiful job with that
I fullheartedly agree we have to pause
really quick to talk about this GI truth
yes yes sorry because I want to talk
about the movie get in the GI but the GI
Joe I mean does that must mean they're
because there was ah okay well let me
just rack my brain here there's the GI
Joe movies there's like the Channing
Tatum one and there's a sequel that
starred Dwayne Johnson which also at
chanting briefly in it and then the
Transformers movies
but then bumblebee it was the prequel to
this Transformers movies and this is the
sequel to the Bumblebee and I feel like
they're kind of doing like a
re-establishing resetting of sorts so I
think they're going to be rebooting GI
Joe then with him and yeah starting off
with Noah joining the the GI Joe team
because for the longest time they've
been saying like you have GI Joe you
should do a Cinematic Universe you
should do a cross like a crossover it's
hasbros it's the same company so make it
happen and then yeah this is them
finally establishing that they're going
to be uh doing that which is which is a
big deal that's cool that's pretty
awesome that's pretty awesome
transforming GI Joe I know imagine them
right working together the soldiers
writing the Transformers how awesome
will that be oh man I was like a huge
Army of Awesomeness
Holy balls
um
all right I got very lucky
that was not spoiled for me
oh I feel like being on the internet
yeah yeah
I got really lucky yeah I mean I
wouldn't I I know anyway I have
Transformers muted on my social medias
because I haven't seen it smart if I
haven't seen it like like if there's
certain movies if I'm like I might have
to end up reacting this so I'm like
scream I would mute any any new releases
I end up just muting it
um if you like type in the movie and
then be like yeah on Twitter you can
mute stuff yeah well well
so yeah there's ways of getting of
avoiding spoilers if you if you try hard
enough
avoiding spoilers
um but no I got I'm very fortunate I'm
very fortunate from you guys for not
spoiling that for me either
um you did good it might be in the
review though with John and Coy uh
David's I obviously haven't watched that
video but it might be in that video uh
anyway sorry because they did a review
of the movie from out of the theater but
yeah let's talk about the movie itself
good thing you didn't watch it yeah you
could think I didn't watch it
um but that that uh that's that's such a
mind-blowing uh reveal to me that's
that's such a big deal so yeah the movie
itself I I like the Transformers movies
a lot of people like the Michael Bay
first one a lot I'm not even a big fan
of that one honestly I am yeah I see a
lot of people really like that one and
I'm not part of that camp uh and then
the sequels
were just not my thing
um I I definitely fell asleep in the
third one so I don't even remember what
happened a lot of people like that one
more than the second one but at that
point I just started really checking out
I really like bumblebee
um a lot I love Bumblebee and so good
what I'll say is like bumblebee is more
like my kind of movie Personally like my
sensibilities and the kind in terms of a
Transformers movie it might not really
fit like that category you know what I
mean but that's more my kind of movie
just that like spirit and that personal
bond between Bumblebee and Haley
Steinfeld but if we're looking in the
Transformers Blockbuster action lens
that box this fulfills it this gave me
finally what I've been wanting the
Transformers movies to be
um where I really like the character I
like the human character there's not a
lot there's just two and instead of the
Michael Bay ones which are like a
billion human characters you don't give
a about and and more importantly
like it really felt like this was about
our Autobots this felt like it was about
the Transformers and they had real
distinguished not all of them that's
that's one of my little complaints about
the movie is that I felt like we could
have gone to know the maximals a little
bit better yeah we could have especially
because it's called rise of the Beast
yeah so you could have got another
maximals a little bit better uh but
excuse me guys I I was really engaged in
that but I am a little bit tired
um but the um and the the uh but overall
like the Autobots the main the main core
I was like wow I'm really invested in
their heart here and I love that Optimus
is it's truly a character this time
around instead of just like a uh like
the the Revere general you know he's
someone who has a character Arc he has
to go on as well here yeah that's
reflective of in our Noah character I
was I was just like wow they're doing
the whole time I was watching this I was
like they're just they're doing all the
things I've wanted the Transformers
movies to do which is not I'm not really
asking for a lot
face a good story you know and um the
fact that they're doing it and you could
tell what's going on in the action like
when you're in the finale
one of the complaints that a lot of us
would have is I'm like this is so messy
and I can't even tell who the bad guys
are and who the good guys are but I was
like right I can tell who the good guys
are and who the bad guys are this is so
well done and I was I was I felt that
wonder you know what I mean yeah I agree
it's like they pulled the parts of
Bumblebee that we all liked where they
do have a deep connection between like
human and and Transformer and they added
it into this movie with multiple uh like
Transformers and then a couple of people
and how they have to come together to
work together to like slave the world
but um I really like the outside
character of the kid like how is that
going to come in with him having sickle
cell and surviving and he's young and he
is fighting through something so
extraordinary at such a young age and of
course at the end he is the one that has
to
um give his brother like I like the pep
talk of his brothers now under
extraordinary circumstances which is
where this 11 year old has lived a lot
of his life is extraordinary
circumstances and has fought through it
and I like that they made that
connection the human connection of like
when he gives that pep talk to his
brother I was like oh God so sad and
like just great just like Bittersweet
and fantastic and those are the moments
that I
always feel like movies that are super
cool they show cool stuff don't have and
that heart right there in that one
moment and there were many others in
this movie luckily uh really sold it for
me like bringing him back in a really
believable way and not just like
throwing it in there of like I'm still
here and still fighting because they
could have just done that they added him
into the story and it just seemed so
seamless and of course his words were
the thing to
uh just to help his brother fight and
continue on and like home team in it man
yeah Propel him up yeah I mean to your
point the that's kind of like reflective
of the whole movie of what I thought
bumblebee did so well and I think the
thing that they carried over here is
they maintained a heart throughout this
entire film and that's kind of what was
getting to me emotionally even when uh
air razor when air razor died was like
yeah I mean air Razor's not like the
most fleshed out character or something
like that
um
and there's a there's also something too
with the fact that it like it's
reflective of an animal and like an
animal test so it will get to me a lot
more uh so yeah like the fact is
reflective of an animal but you see how
like uh Optimus primal was trying to not
kill her and the toll it takes and that
was the thing that stood out to me here
was wow you really get the sense that
even even for the ones you don't really
get like you don't really get to know
the the
maximals that well uh for them like you
need to get to know a couple of them
like primarily Primal you don't really
know them that well there's some of the
auto bets you don't really get to know
super well
but regardless of that you really get
the sense of they they really do love
each other they really do care about
each other yeah and that was enough to
permeate the screen to make me feel
connected to those moments was just that
driving force of them of Love uh as they
were trying they were fighting to
protect you know what I mean because
that's the the plot of like Autobots and
Cybertron and then we need to go back to
Cybertron and defend Earth and it's it's
a lot of the same beats sure
um
but it just hit differently here because
there was a motion
there was a motion uh layered into those
scenes and even in some of the
the thing is I have a hard time usually
with these big CGI Fest movies
connecting because I'm so aware that
it's CGI and this movie managed to uh
surpass that you know what I mean like I
managed to still connect with it even
when it was a big Siege it's a CGI Fest
the entire time like yeah but yet it's
I'm still like connected to what was
happening and I was I guess I was like
surprised by how connected I thought I
was just going to be like there's gonna
be cool action and then there's gonna be
scenes in between to fill the runtime
and then I was watching it like I'm
actually really invested in what's
happening right now yeah and and because
they managed to just weave a good story
who's your favorite Transformer oh good
question but I was gonna say that air
Razor's like a mom and there's the
moment when she says just do it to
Primal and he is holding her and she and
in that quote of saying above all else I
was like she's the mama bird who has
taught them Above All Else Like You know
what you need to do now he has taken me
over with his shitty virus excuse my
language but like and then when he when
he grabs her we see primal's pain in his
face exactly and it freaking kills me
it's it's it's almost like a you see
sort of it's just like a kid having to
like kill his mom a little bit like we
see a kinship a friendship there he
doesn't want to do it but he's been
taught like now he has to and that's
like oh it's that ripped my heart out
that was tough but that just like again
was just like a huge it's a huge piece
of heart that like you take that with
you and you see like how they've carried
themselves and what they've been taught
and and especially in them
um protecting the humans meeting that
tribe and that tribe it was given the
key and like that's how optimists also
see you see from learning and Optimus
sees them and learns that now oh you
trust humans oh we can trust humans and
that is now going to be the only way
that they all can overtake him is now
entrusting humans with them all work
together home team in it it's you make
such a great point about the motherly
quality because that's Michelle yo
voices air razor by the way oh man
um and it because the motherly moment
that switch that happened for me with
her was so early on when
um when she first meets the autobots and
then she turns to when Elena's like oh I
know where the thing is it's in Peru and
then when she turns to Elena and that's
Elena right now she turns to Elena and
says like are you going to be coming
with us like the way that delivery in
that moment was done I was like oh
there's something so tender about the
way she's asking her yeah in that moment
I'm like I suddenly feel like connected
to you because she was also the only one
who asked her name yeah exactly yeah
yeah that was that that one that's what
I mean it's like you see these little
nuances to really elevate your movie and
I'm surprises has taken the Transformers
movies like this long this long to come
I mean they had like that one director
Michael Bay first like five of them and
then who did a good job at like a guest
establishing a sense of action
um but yeah I mean and the action's good
too like the action is is great it's
just I we always talk about like if it's
a horror I want to see some cool stuff
but I also want to care about what's the
people in it like uh otherwise it's just
a noise yeah yeah it's just like oh I
don't care Greg kill some more people
like nobody cares uh and they did a
great job of showing us action giving us
that really fun uh Transformers juice
that we all want yeah well also still
feeding us with characters that we
really enjoy seeing and caring about
crying about and loving that's the juice
it reminded me of the physicality
because a lot of times in this
Transformers movies when you watch the
action it is like okay I'm watching
things Collide and in here when when
they were like ripping each other apart
or getting hit I was like oh I actually
I feel that feel it like as if it's a
human being here you know what I mean
like you said you've when you saw it
felt like it looked like a tendons like
a piece of yeah which which is a great
way to get you hooked into the act and I
think bumblebee had a similar effect but
I don't will be the one time so I don't
remember too well but here with a bunch
of with a bunch of the actions like oh
you actually feel the weight of the of
them getting hit you feel you feel the
impact it's not just big loud things
hitting each other and choreography
you're like oh there's there's actual
anatomy of what's happening right now
and uh and I appreciated uh that that
context and it just looked cool too it
did look cool but it's easier to make
look cool than it is for things to
feel substantial or feel like Stakes
yeah I agree
um I I can't ever remember this freaking
actor's name and I feel like it's not a
hard name to remember uh let me just
fight it Anthony Ramos it's not a hard
name to remember Anthony Ramos is is a
is a gem of an actor he's going to be so
so much bigger than he he's already
getting like really big but he's a prime
time nice Prime Time nice touch nice
touch Dominic Fishback or yeah Dominique
Fishback I don't know who that is
that little kid was so good did you know
voice Mirage did you pick up on The
Voice did you pick up on the voice no
who was it yes take one guess
he's a comedian he's a funny man
he dates nothing but really hot famous
women
come on that's gotta be the biggest clue
people are always making fun of how he
dates nothing but really hot famous
woman and he's a funny guy
well is it is it Kanye West hates him
Kanye West hates him I don't know I
don't follow a lot of is it Chris Rock
no he's like probably married oh wait is
it Kevin Hart no I would recognize Kevin
Hart from anywhere is it
um see I'm not gonna be good at this
game is it who hates him what did you
say hey oh my God Kanye West hates
everybody
um
commit
I don't oh wait he was Mexican right it
was he
I don't know this is not gonna be a game
I'm gonna win who was it Pete Davidson
oh really yeah oh my God yes of course
when you said he hates him oh my God I'm
so not I'm not up on the juice I knew
like two months of him and Kardash like
dating I was like I don't read I don't
read the the Vogue uh headlines in who's
dating who anyway okay yes now I'm with
it yeah I'm with it now yeah I liked him
I could see how that's a character
people might not be able to get on board
with because there's a couple of points
if you're like turn down the jokes a
little bit Yeah but more often than not
I was like
um I find this charming and it's it's a
different take on the whole because
normally it's like make Bumblebee the
one who's connected to the human you
know that's normally what they do and
this was a different kind of this is a
different kind of take and sometimes was
a little too jokey sure but more often
than not I know Transformers like became
famous from like being an 80s cartoon
and there was a lot about the
personalities like sort of reminded me
of that yeah like art some of the voice
works on like RC the the girl who's like
acrobatic and the yeah the bike the
Ducati yeah yeah yeah and then uh and
then Pete Davidson too who just reminded
me of like an 80s reminder of like 80s
characters to me so I I is like an 80s
character yeah so I thought it was funny
I thought it was funny and Charming I
did too
um good music all around everything was
good uh yeah my only complaint really is
that uh I just kind of wish I got to
know some of those the maximum they call
it rise of the Beast and I kind of wish
I gotta know them a little more maybe in
the next one we will that's my main my
main little thing and better than that
no man it's such an improvement over
what that came before that I'm like I
got I got no complaints the fact that
it's such an improvement uh like
Nine Stars Nine Stars Nine Stars baby
that's where we're at ladies and
gentlemen what are your nitpicks leave
them down below uh make sure to follow
Tara thank you to all who followed us on
our patreon page and
um yeah uh I think we should the patron
of the day shout out Maria Hammond now
Maria I give sincere shout outs to Maria
okay all right because we were talking
in a review about how uh air razor had
such a motherly tender quality and I am
often saying about Maria that in a lot
of ways you know yes mother in real life
but specifically uh to us and and to me
as well she's constantly
with more than just actual physical
gifts and she gives us quite a lot of
gifts and even Olivia she sends Olivia
quite a lot of gifts too that's so sweet
but also just like the words of wisdom
and uh the the just the overall tender
messages that she constantly sends us so
it's just an overwhelming amount of love
and support like when I say overwhelming
it's overwhelming like there's no one
else really out there like you to treats
us this way can I get a message Maria
yes
Tara needs some love man turning some
love Maria so I just want to say I love
you and thank you for the love that
you're constantly flowing our way that
energy is always well received and and
it's something that we definitely need
we feed off your love Maria so thank you
for being you and yeah what the I need
to adjust that she got us that cool
thing back there that I need to adjust
so thank you for being you and uh
looking forward to another lovely
message from you soon and I'm looking
forward to mine bye take character
foreign